to the parents who tell their children
to run into the bathtub when they hear
gunfire on the street outside
because it is the safest place in the
home
from a stray bullet
gun violence brings pain
to the entire community
and by extension
to the whole of society
as a prosecutor i brought many
perpetrators of gun violence to justice
but i knew
even after a successful prosecution
the hurt
and the loss
and the fear
often still remained
to the survivors of gun violence who are
here with us today
and to the friends and family members of
those we have lost
i thank you
for your incredible determination
in the face of so much pain
and it is a deep honor
to stand with you today
as we know all too well
our nation continues to be plagued
by an epidemic of gun violence
the president has worked for decades
to end this terror
for my whole career addressing gun
violence has been one of my top
priorities first as a courtroom
prosecutor
then as the elected district attorney of
san francisco when we created a gun
specialist unit
to go after violent offenders
then as attorney general of california
where we worked within our california
bureau of firearms to investigate and
seize firearms for those who unlawfully
possess them
i have seen firsthand
how our nation's epidemic of gun
violence
has been driven
by the prolification proliferation
excuse me
of guns in our communities
and increasingly in recent years
by the proliferation of ghost guns
ghost guns can be purchased on the
internet
and assembled at a kitchen table
they can be bought without a background
check
by people who otherwise would be legally
prohibited from gun ownership
domestic abusers
gun traffickers
individuals convicted of violent crimes
and even young children
traditional guns
are required to have serial numbers
which can help law enforcement identify
a firearm that has been stolen from its
lawful owner or found at the scene of a
crime
ghost guns have no serial numbers
they are practically untraceable
making it more difficult for law
enforcement to hold to account
those who use weapons to do violence
because of how easy they are to access
and how difficult they are to trace
ghost guns pose an especially grave
threat
to the safety of our communities
that is why as a united states senator i
was proud to co-sponsor a bill to
manufacture and end the manufacturing
excuse me of sale of ghost guns and it
is why we are here today
to announce new actions to get ghost
guns off our streets and to protect our
communities from gun violence
[Applause]
the department of justice
plays a critical role
in addressing gun violence in our
communities
and the actions we are taking today
would not be possible without their
partnership
so i'm proud to now welcome a leader who
has spearheaded much of the department's
work on this important issue
deputy attorney general lisa monaco
[Applause]
thank you very much madam vice president
mr president mia
there is no higher priority for the
department of justice than keeping the
american people safe
that is why every day
we work with our community and law
enforcement partners to combat violent
crime through prevention
and through prosecutions
too often though
murders and other serious crimes are
committed with guns
each victim of gun violence
is
someone's loved one a neighbor a friend
we stand together today
in recognition of that loss
and alongside all of those who have been
touched by the tragedy of gun violence
we also stand together with resolve
and with hope for the future
just over one year ago
the president the vice president and the
attorney general stood in this very spot
to announce new steps to curb gun
violence
one such critical step is reining in
so-called ghost guns
these are guns that have no serial
numbers they are nearly impossible for
law enforcement to trace
many are sold without a background check
they're accessible to almost anyone
they often come in kits they can be
bought online
they can be assembled quickly with
little or no training
that means that someone can convert
parts in a box
into a working gun
with alarming ease
now we call them ghost guns because they
can't be traced but make no mistake
they are real they can shoot to kill
and they do
for years criminals have sought out
these unmarked guns to murder and to
maim
that's why
the attorney general has signed a rule
that updates our regulations to keep up
with changes in technology
the goal to keep untraceable guns off of
the streets out of the hands of
criminals and others who are prohibited
by law from possessing a firearm
some of the key changes include updating
old definitions to ensure that gun laws
apply to all firearms including ghost
guns
requiring gun dealers to run background
checks on kits containing parts that can
readily be converted into a gun
facilitating tracing by requiring
firearms dealers to apply serial numbers
to existing ghost guns
so that they then take into inventory
because of these updates law enforcement
will have additional crime gun
intelligence to stop gun violence
to seek justice for victims of violent
crimes and to get guns used in crimes
off of our streets
today's announcement is one of many
efforts by the department of justice to
protect our communities from violent
crime and gun violence
we continue to go after and disrupt
illegal gun trafficking networks
we continue to go after and hold
accountable the most violent offenders
and we are working every day with our
partners in law enforcement and with
community leaders to craft specific
strategies to combat violent crime and
keep communities safe
we will not stop until we reduce violent
crime and save lives
as the attorney general has said the
department will continue to pro to apply
every single tool at our disposal to
fulfill that obligation
and now it is my great honor to
introduce mia tretta an inspiring young
woman whose story illustrates why we're
here today
and why these actions are so important
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much deputy attorney
general
good afternoon
as she said my name is mia tretta and
it's an honor to be here today
and not just because it's the white
house
but because i'm speaking on behalf of
two classmates who can't be here with us
one of whom was my best friend
when i woke up on november 14 2019 my
biggest worry of the day was a spanish
test
i was a freshman at saugus high school
in santa clarita california
determined to get good grades
so as soon as i got to school i made a b
line for the quad to meet up with my
best friend dominic blackwell
it's hard for me to talk about dominic
like me dominic had big dreams
liked doing well in school and planning
for our futures
we spent the morning like any other
laughing talking
until we heard a loud pop
it was a gunshot
followed by six more
one of the bullets hit me in the stomach
somehow i was able to get up and run
away
but dominic couldn't
i was airlifted to the hospital and
spent hours in surgery having a bullet
removed from my abdomen that was
millimeters away from my major artery
then my parents told me the terrible
truth
dominic had died
and so had another classmate gracie ann
muellberger a fifteen-year-old girl with
an infectious laugh
and a community was left shattered
i later learned that we had been shot by
a 16 year old student
for reasons i will never know
he had brought his father's weapon to
school
a firearm i would come to know as a
ghost gun
ghost guns are untraceable
build-it-yourself firearms that look
like a gun
shoot like a gun
and kill like a gun but have not been
regulated like a gun
i've also learned that as a student i
don't just have to worry about spanish
tests
but about my life
school shootings with ghost guns are on
the rise
and the most lasting thing i have
learned
other than the loss of friends or the
shattering of my youth
is that nothing has
that nothing has relieved the pain of my
heart
like working to prevent more senseless
shootings
so my family and i joined every town for
gun safety moms demand action and
students demand action
and we worked with thousands of other
young activists and survivors
to prevent more things like this
happening
they turned my pain into progress
and that's why we're here today
celebrating progress
life-saving progress
[Applause]
because now
finally
we have a president who realizes that
thoughts and prayers alone are not
enough
a president who has been standing up to
the gun lobby for decades and winning
a president
who has been standing up for survivors
like me and so many others
a president who is taking bold
meaningful action to stop the spread of
ghost guns
ladies and gentlemen it is now my great
honor to introduce the strongest gun
sense commander in chief ever to hold
office
president joe biden
[Music]
wow
thank you madam vice president
deputy attorney general monaco
and mia
you're an incredible young woman
we spoke for a moment inside the oval
office
and uh
a lot of people here who have lost
someone too many here have lost someone
know that
no matter what the occasion how
celebratory or not it is
when you have to repeat it you relive it
like it just happened a moment ago
your poise your confidence
and your intellect
are really impressive honey i mean they
really are
and you know
i think most people here can tell you've
gone through serious loss
that uh the best way to deal with this
find purpose
and you found real purpose
and uh
you are impressive
and thank you for sharing your strength
for helping us remember your friend
dominic blackwell
and gracie muellberger
you know uh
dominic and gracie's parents are with us
today you prepared to stand up if i
don't want to embarrass you but would
you stand up
[Applause]
if you have a moment afterwards maybe
you can come in the oval with me if you
wouldn't mind i'd love to talk to you
frank and nancy brian and cindy
everyone here
as they say
feels your pain a little bit
particularly if they've suffered a
serious loss
you've now joined a terrible fellowship
of loss
that many people have experienced
there are too many survivors and
advocates here for me to name everyone
today but let me say
the loss in this crowd is incalculable
but so is the strength
so is the strength
i believe our nation will be safer for
your bravery and i really mean that
survivors like me and manny and claudia
los angeles deputy sheriff who survived
and ambushed by a shooter of the ghost
gun represent individuals and families
all across this country
whose lives have been forever changed
by a ghost gun
some made national headlines many others
did not
today we honor your strength and your
action
a year ago this week standing here with
many of you i instructed the attorney
general
to write a regulation that would reign
in the proliferation of ghost guns
because i was having trouble getting
passed in the congress
but i used what we call
regulatory authority
a year later
we're here we keep that promise
the gun lobby tried to tie up the
regulators and paperwork for a long long
time
the nra called this rule i'm about to
announce extreme
extreme
but let me ask you is it extreme to
protect
extreme to keep guns out of the hands of
people who couldn't even pass a
background check
look the idea that
someone on a terrorist list
could purchase one of these guns
is extreme it didn't extreme just basic
common sense
you know
if you buy a couch you have to assemble
it's still a couch
if you order a package like this one
over here
that includes the parts you need the
direction of assembling a functioning
firearm you bought a gun take a look
take a look at this it comes in this
package
you can see the picture down here maybe
this is the gun
it's not hard
to put together
a little drill hand drill at home
doesn't take very long
anyone
can order it
anyone
folks
a felon a terrorist a domestic abuser
can go from a gun kit
to a gun as little as 30 minutes
buyers aren't required to pass
background checks
because guns have no serial numbers
these guns
when they show up at a crime scene they
can't be traced
harder to find and prove who used them
mean you can't connect the gun to the
shooter
and hold them accountable
in fact the atf reports that they've
been able to trace less than one percent
less than one percent
of ghost guns reported by law
enforcement
so it makes sense
the police across the country
are increasingly finding ghost guns at
crime scenes and by the way ghost guns
can be quote rifles essentially assault
weapons as well this is one version
of the kit you can buy
last year alone
law enforcement reported approximately
20 000
suspected ghost guns to be
to the bureau of alcohol tobacco
firearms and explosives
that's a tenfold increase
in these ghost guns from 2016.
tenfold
in five years
these guns are weapons of choice for
many criminals
we're going to do everything we can to
deprive them of that choice
and when we find them put them in jail
for a long long time
law enforcement is sounding the alarm
our communities are paying the price and
we're acting today the united states
department of justice is making it
illegal
for a business to manufacture one of
these kits without a serial number
illegal
illegal for a licensed gun dealer to
sell them without a background check
and starting today weapons like the one
used in saugus high school
and to ambush deputies with us that are
here with us today are being treated
like the deadly firearms they are
and if somebody sells a ghost gun to a
federally licensed dealer for example a
pawn shop
that dealer must make the firearm and
mark it with a serial number before
reselling it
all of a sudden
it's no longer a ghost
it has a return address
it's going to help save lives reduce
crime
and get more criminals off the streets
and this rule is only part of our
strategy to go after ghost guns in
february the department of justice
launched the nation a national gun ghost
gun enforcement initiative intensifying
our efforts to bring cases against those
who use ghost guns illegally
we're teaching investigators and
prosecutors best practices how to build
these cases
and assigning a coordinator in each of
the atf field divisions to serve as a
point person prepping federal state and
local law enforcement go after ghost
guns
if you commit a crime with a ghost gun
expect federal prosecution i just say
expect federal prosecution
[Applause]
this rule is an important step
it's going to make a difference i
promise you
and a lot of other things we know work
to reduce gun violence
and other violent crimes and save lives
that's why i put together a
comprehensive strategy to supercharge
what works
while continuing to push congress to act
on sensible legislation to rent gun
violence
in addition to date in addition to
today's rule we're working on four areas
first
we're going after rogue gun dealers
the last time we had data on this was
more than 20 years ago
five percent of gun dealers sold ninety
percent of illegal guns found in crime
scenes five percent sold ninety percent
these merchants of death
are breaking law for profit selling guns
that are killing innocent people
we're cracking down on these gun dealers
and the violent criminals they knowingly
are
second
we're we're disrupting illegal gun
trafficking attorney general garland
and has directed all u.s attorneys to
prioritize combating gun trafficking
that is moving guns across state lines
and city boundaries
the justice department is surging
prosecutor resources to help shut down
these trafficking corridors including
the one known as the iron
pipeline
that funnels weapons
from gun shops in states like georgia to
crime scenes
up and down the east coast
thirdly
we're funding strategy we know reduced
gun crime
community policing and community
violence interruption
look
i've said it many times
the answer is not to defund the police
it's to fund the police and give them
the tools and training to support they
need to be better partners and
protectors of our communities in need
[Applause]
i've already made clear that i want city
states counties and tribes
to use some of the
350 billion dollars we sent to them in
the american rescue plan that i wrote in
the first month to reduce gun violence
hire police officers for community
policing pay police overtime purchase
crime fighting technologies they were
given the money they can do it
spend it
[Applause]
now on top of that i'm calling for
additional funding to put police on the
streets for community policing one thing
we learned
in the middle of the crime wave not long
ago
when the cop knows
by first name
who owns the corner drugstore who lives
in the apartment above
6b who the people who are the the
pastors of the churches
guess what
people talk to them
they trust them
my son was the attorney general in
delaware he'd go around
and make sure everybody literally in
these high crime rate neighborhoods he'd
give them his personal cell phone number
and instructed all the cops to do the
same thing
and they did
and the crime plummeted not a joke look
at the record
not just my son but all across the
nation
for the ft to hire agents they need to
help to fight
gun crime more agents
my budget funds body cameras make sure
police work with our local communities
and are accountable to the local
communities
we're also investing in community
violence intervention
these are areas of local programs that
utilize trusted messengers community
members and leaders to work directly
with people who are most likely to
commit a gun crime or become victims of
gun crime get to them early it works
it works
they intervened before it's too late
fourth
for funding jobs and training for young
people summer programs drug treatment
mental health housing availability
criminal justice reform and reentry
support for people coming home after
incarceration
right now
you get let out of prison after serving
your time you get a bus ticket and 25
bucks
you end up under the same bridge you
left
two five ten years earlier
if you serve your time
you qualify for pell grants you qualify
for housing you're qualified for food
you qualify to get back into the
community give them a fighting chance
these are all
demonstrated ways to reduce crime
and i'm strongly urging cities states
counties and tribes
to use the rescue plan funding we sent
them to do more in each of these areas
the need to do more and do it quickly
before the summer when crime typically
surges around america
so
we're pushing in each of these areas but
none of this absolves congress of all
due respect to my members of congress
here they're the wrong people i'd be
talking to
for the responsibility to act
we need congress to pass
universal background checks
universal background checks
and i know it's controversial but i got
it done once ban assault weapons and
high capacity magazines
i was getting
criticized when i first passed this law
when i was a senator
and guess what
i was down in southern delaware to do a
lot of hunting and fishing down there
and i was walking up one of the creek
beds and the guy's standing so you want
to take my gun i said i'm going to take
your gun so you're telling me i can't
have more of the next number of bullets
in a and a in my gun
and i said what do you think the deer
you're hunting or wear kevlar vest what
the hell you need 20 bullets for you
must be a hell of a terrible shot
i'm serious think about it
think about the mass shootings
as many as 100 rounds
it's a weapon of war
there's nothing to do
with recreation
outright banning the sale and possession
of
unserialized guns
eliminate gun manufacturers immunity
from liabilities the only outfit
for the only outfit in the country
that is immune
imagine had the tobacco industry been
immune
to prostitute being sued come on
in february the families of nine of the
sandy hook shooting victims
achieved a settlement against the maker
of guns that was used to kill their
children the sandy
sandy hook folks are here were you
embarrassed to ask you to stand up
these folks right here
did more to keep all this going than
anybody
we owe you man
we owe you
it never goes away does it
god love you
look this is incredibly rare because gun
manufacturers have more immunity from
liability than any other american
industry
so they've never had to take
responsibility for the death and
destruction their products caused
but as part of this settlement remington
agreed to release thousands of pages of
internal documents you did that
and why here's why it's so important
remember it wasn't until we saw the
internal documents that we really
understood what cigarette manufacturers
are doing to our kids and our families
now
we may begin to see what gun
manufacturers are and are not doing when
it comes to making and marketing their
deadly products
and by the way
it's going to sound bizarre i support
the second amendment
you have a right
but from the very beginning the second
amendment didn't say you can own any gun
you want as big as you want you couldn't
buy a cannon when in fact the second
amendment passed
and certain people from the very
beginning weren't allowed to purchase
guns
there's nothing new it's just rational
look this should be just a start we need
to repeal the liability shield of gun
manufacturing and finally hold them
accountable for false advertising and
many other things they do
there's one more action i'm taking today
it's only been
there's only been one senate who's
confirmed the director of bureau of
alcohol tobacco firearms and explosives
in the bureau's entire history
it used to be didn't require standard
action when i first got to the senate
but it's only been one sense it became
required
confirmation
this is an agency whose mission is to
protect communities from violent
criminals
illegal trafficking of firearms
acts of arson and bombing and a lot more
the mission of this agency isn't
controversial it's public safety
today
to lead and support the dedicated men
and women of the aft i'm proud to
nominate
steve
duttleback excuse me i mispronounced
your name i just was
a director of bureau of a bureau of
alcohol tobacco farms and explosives
steve is immensely qualified
he served
the department of justice for two
decades he worked side by side to
support the work of federal state and
local law enforcement including aft
agents
and one of those was his
case he was personally
tried as a u.s attorney where the serial
arsonists firebombed the courthouses and
police headquarters in mansfield ohio
for his work steve got death threats
but the defendant got 60 years
steve also partnered with the community
leaders and law enforcement to help
prevent violent crime he's worked with
the police to combat domestic extremism
and to take violent criminals off the
street
steve's record makes him ready on day
one to lead this agencies
and by the way in 2009 the u.s senate
unanimously confirmed him to serve as
u.s attorney
i look forward to working with the
senate to get him confirmed once again
with what i've uh
know about him and why i'm so
enthusiastic i support him i'd like to
introduce my nominee to lead the aft to
you all of you steve come on up here
thank you mr president
thank you vice president harris for your
leadership in protecting the people of
this nation and for placing your trust
in me
to become the next director of the atf
thank you also uh deputy attorney
general monaco for all that you and
attorney general garland continue to do
at doj to make our nation safer and
thank you mia for your incredible
inspiration and courage not just here
today but all over this nation thank you
i also want to thank my incredible
supportive and often patient family who
are here
my wonderful wife carol
and my children
ali and david please
he's 16 years old i'm going to draft him
is there an agent in the house
but seriously more most especially today
i want to thank the men
and women of the atf
you know i started as a career
prosecutor back in 1992 and i have spent
three decades
watching and admiring agents and staff
at the atf along with its federal state
and local law enforcement partners as
they work tirelessly and courageously to
protect the american people
i would also say they work in anonymity
but that would not be completely true
because sadly one thing i've also seen
over the years is that the atf
often does work in anonymity when its
agents are out there risking their lives
to protect us
only to be thrust into the public eye
when it's time for criticism
law enforcement is a very tough job
and no person and no agency
is perfect
but the president is right the men and
women of the atf
and the public that they protect deserve
better support from us
i've seen firsthand the work that so
many at the atf do to protect us from
violence they're dedicated they're
professional and they're effective they
don't write the laws their mission every
day is just to go out and enforce those
laws and protect the public from a wide
range of threats
when i was u.s attorney our office
partnered with the atf and the cleveland
police as they doggedly investigated and
brought a case involving the deadliest
home arson in cleveland history killed
nine people including eight kids
i also saw the atf partner with the fbi
and our office first to find and then to
bring to justice a bigot who drove from
indiana to outside toledo to torch the
largest mosque in ohio
and last and certainly not least
i have partnered with the atf for
decades in its crucial fight against gun
violence you know whether it was taking
a single violent recidivist off the
street in maryland
or putting together a big racketeering
case against a violent gang in
youngstown ohio
i have seen the atf work with other law
enforcement to make so many of our
communities safer
as we emerge from this pandemic
got to recognize that many americans
still face fear
and isolation not because of a virus
but because of an epidemic of firearms
violence
it's not a new problem
and it has many causes
that's why it's going to take an all
hands on deck partnership approach to
address that shoe
and the atf will
be
there
[Applause]
if confirmed i promise to support
the men
the women of the atf
and to do everything in our power
to protect the people of this nation
every single day
thank you
[Applause]
thank you all for coming by the way he
was responsible for the weather as well
thank you thank you thank you
ladies and gentlemen please remain in
your seats as the president and vice
president depart thank you
[Music]
from
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
is
[Music]